the the final
paper
uh not the final but the last one i got
interested in
was written in uh the late 40s by a
couple of german
physicists at guertingan
and the
they had been contacted by an eye doctor
at the the clinic and of course the way
medicine works is that you know the
local doctors will
solve all the cases they know how to
solve and if they find something they
can't help they
refer it up the food chain to the next
doctor and it is so things keep moving
up and so if you're the head of the eye
clinic at gurthangan it means you're the
most eminent
eye doctor in the german speaking world
okay
so one day this this guy comes to work
and in his waiting room is a man
who's got floaters he's he can see
little
dark specks floating around in his
vision which is a very common thing so
this is like if you're the most
important dermatologist in the world and
somebody comes to see you about a
freckle right
um but he he looks into the guy's eye
and he sees tumbling around in the guy's
vitreous humor he sees little tiny metal
rods
they're obviously metal they're
obviously man-made
and they're just floating around loose
inside of his eyeball which is perfectly
undamaged there's no
no
entry wound nothing like that
so
he's completely mystified he asked the
guy you know what did you do during the
war were you
in an explosion or you know anything
like that and the guy goes no i i didn't
fight you know i was a civilian
uh well what do you do for a living well
i drive a truck
well do you ever
like maybe stick your head out the
window or were you ever in a crash you
know or anything like that no nothing
like that doctor
so
eventually he had to give up and and
write it off as a mystery of of science
but then a a few months later a few
months later another guy shows up
same symptoms exactly the same thing
no explanation for it and then another
and another so
he starts trying to put the pieces
together and figure out what is the
common thread among all of these people
and it turns out the one thing they all
have in common is that they're drivers
which
by then meant driving trucks
but during the war uh because we had
targeted their um
uh the the germans uh of
fuel production
there had been a lot of trucks lying
around that couldn't be operated uh
because there was no fuel so
they had gone back to hauling them
behind animals and they had had the
improvised harnesses
and yolks and all that stuff because it
was all gone nobody had used it for
decades
and that was all easily invented from
ropes and straps and whatever they had
lying around but the hard thing was
getting whips
because whips have some pretty specific
properties that they have to have if
they're going to crack correctly but
some genius figured out that
one thing they had all over germany by
that point was collapsed to buildings
and a lot of those buildings had running
down the outside a braided copper
grounding cable
and if you just went up to one of them
and cut off a length of that stuff and
you know did the right motion you could
get that thing to crack like a whip
and a thing that a lot of novice whip
crackers do
is that they'll jerk the whip toward
them to make it snap which is really
dangerous because it comes back at you
but it's a really easy way to get it to
crack every time
and so the the doctor said um you know
did it ever happen when you were doing
that you like would you know feel you
know one of these sharp pains in your
eye
and they said yeah that happens
sometimes but you know you just kind of
blink it away and a few minutes later
you know it's like nothing ever happened
so he goes running across the campus to
the physics department and he
buttonholes a couple of physicists and
he says
is it physically plausible that if you
cracked a copper grounding cable like a
whip that the tensile strength of the
copper out at the end would get exceeded
to the point where it would snap
and if so would it would the pieces be
going fast enough that they could fly
through the air for a few feet and
penetrate somebody's eyeball and come to
a stop
inside the vitreous humor so the
physicist you know i mean this is all
the whole story is in a footnote it's
compressed into a footnote on page one
of this of this paper and then the rest
of the paper is them uh working out all
the physics of whip cracking and proving
that you know all of those things could
could happen
um
so as you can tell that's been a kind of
a personal
uh obsession of mine for
i'd say that story qualifies as stranger
than fiction
[Music]